La cigale ayant chanté tout l’été…
Vous connaissez la fable ?
Ce n’est pas une légende !
Il y en a plein autour de moi.
J’adore les entendre chanter pendant
les vacances. Je vous envoie une carte ?
En France, on les trouve
essentiellement autour de la Méditerranée.
On en a comptabilisé une dizaine
d'espèces différentes.
Chez les cigales, c’est monsieur qui chante.
Je vais vous montrer.
Voici le chanteur et sa groupie.
Madame et monsieur.
Ils sont à la même échelle.
Comme vous pouvez le constater, il y a
très peu de différences entre les deux.
Pas de dimorphisme sexuel,
comme disent les biologistes.
Peut-être aurez-vous simplement remarqué
la présence de ce petit conduit chez la femelle :
l’ovipositeur qui lui permet
de déposer ses œufs.
Alors les cigales chantent
depuis très longtemps.
Les dinosaures faisaient déjà la sieste
au chant des cigales.
Ce sont des maquettes. Dans la nature,
les cigales sont beaucoup plus discrètes.
On va essayé
d’en trouver une…
On les entend bien,
mais elles ne sont pas faciles à dénicher.
Elles se confondent avec l’écorce des arbres…
En fait, il faut y aller à l’oreille.
Par là…
Tiens,
en voilà une.
Les mâles chantent pour attirer
les femelles et se reproduire.
Eh bien dites donc Mesdames,
vous avez le choix…
Allez ! Allons voir de quoi
sont équipés ces messieurs…
Je parle des organes
dédiés au chant bien entendu.
J’ai une révélation à vous faire : la cigale
ne chante pas, elle joue d’un instrument.
Des cymbales !
On dit d‘ailleurs qu’elle cymbalise.
Des cymbales, pas tout a fait
comme celles-ci.
Elles ont la forme d’une amande
ou d’un ballon de rugby.
Elles sont constituées d’une membrane, renforcée par des petites côtes légèrement incurvées.
Les instruments se trouvent sous les ailes,
au niveau de la dernière patte. Une de chaque côté.
Alors, la cigale n’en joue pas en les frappant
l’une contre l’autre avec ses petites pattes.
Pour produire un son, elle contracte
le muscle situé juste au-dessus.
La cymbale se déforme, chaque côte
se redresse l’une après l’autre et ça claque.
Un peu comme
cette pince à cheveux.
Quand le muscle se relâche, les côtes reprennent
une à une leur place initiale et ça claque à nouveau.
Tout cela va très vite. Quand la cigale chante, le muscle se contracte une centaine de fois par seconde !
Le son est ensuite recueilli dans une cavité creuse
située au niveau de l’abdomen
qui agit comme la caisse de résonance
d’une guitare ou d’un ukulélé.
Ce qui permet
d’amplifier le son !
La cigale est l’insecte
le plus bruyant de la planète !
Le record a été enregistré
avec une cigale australienne : 120 dB !
Ce qui correspond au bruit
d’un avion au décollage !
Heureusement, nos cigales métropolitaines
sont moins bruyantes : 80 dB.
Ce qui correspond quand même
au bruit d’un aspirateur !
Evidemment, c’est moins sympa
pour faire la sieste.
Et là, tout le monde se pose la même question : comment font-elles pour ne pas devenir sourdes ?
Comme nous, les cigales
sont équipées d’un tympan :
une membrane qui se met à vibrer
quand une onde sonore la rencontre.
C’est ce qui fait sauter
les grains de sel.
Quand la cigale chante, elle relâche
la tension de son tympan.
Celui-ci ne peut plus vibrer.
Elle se rend sourde en quelque sorte !
Elle ne s’écoute pas chanter elle.
Mais pourquoi ne chante-t-elle que pendant l’été
et uniquement la journée ?
Vous vous souvenez du muscle
qui actionne les cymbales ?
Il ne peut se contracter
que s’il est assez souple.
Pour cela,
il lui faut de la chaleur :
au moins 20°C… jusqu'à 24°C
pour les cigales plus grosses.
Quand l’été s’achève
ou quand la nuit tombe…
la température est trop basse, leurs muscles sont trop raides, elles ne peuvent plus chanter.
Mais ce n’est pas tout. Si elles
ne chantent plus à l’arrivée de l’automne,
c’est parce que leur vie d’adulte
est très courte.
La cigale passe le plus clair de sa vie sous nos pieds,
dans le sol au stade larvaire.
Cette période dure de 2 à 5 ans
pour les cigales de nos régions.
Le moment venu, au printemps, elle sort de terre, grimpe sur un tronc et entame sa dernière mue.
Elle laisse derrière elle
une belle exuvie
puis s’envole vers la cime des arbres
pour se reproduire.
C’est à ce moment
que les mâles chantent.
Une fois fécondées, les femelles
redescendent sur le plancher des vaches.
Puis elles pondent sur une tige
ou une écorce. Ensuite, elles meurent.
Je sais, c’est triste.
Mais au bout de quelques semaines,
les œufs éclosent
et des centaines de larves tombent au sol
et s’enfouissent dans la terre…
C’est l‘histoire de la vie,
le cycle éternel !
Ça me rappelle
quelque chose ça…
Autrement dit : une cigale adulte - comme celle ci -,
ne vit que 3 à 4 semaines…
Désolé Monsieur de la Fontaine,
mais quand la bise fut venue,
la cigale n’alla pas crier famine
chez la fourmi sa voisine.
Ça, c’est une légende…
Que faisiez-vous au temps chaud ?
Vous chantiez ?
Eh bien...
dormez maintenant !
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo, n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleu et à vous abonner.
Très bonne fin de vacances
à toutes et à tous,
je vous retrouve dans 2 semaines
à la rentrée !